our main priority as a bureau is going
to be domestic terrorism really paints
anybody who's right of Center if you're
a pro-life Pro Family Catholic they
Define you as radical these are
anti-government we have freedom of
religion and freedom of speace violent
extremists and they must be dealt
[Music]
with I'm very sorry that this movie even
has to be made I'm very sorry that this
movie even could be made in the United
States today but my friend inesh duza
has made it because the political
situation that we're all living in has
degraded to the point that it is
necessary that would be the movie police
state you can go to polic state fm.net
to get your tickets whether you want to
go see it in theaters whether you want
the virtual Premiere that's where you go
police state fm.net
Danes thanks for coming on it's a real
pleasure thanks for having
me if if you had made this movie 10
years ago 15 years ago certainly I would
have said denesh you are being
hyperbolic you're a catastrophist this
is insane give me a break and now you
make the movie and I think oh man I wish
you'd made it two years ago because the
situation seems to be getting worse by
the
day I mean I'm an immigrant you know I'm
an Enthusiast about a America I'm
psychologically you know very much of an
optimist by
temperament um I've experienced the
American dream I've been thrilled to
live in a country where we have basic
rights enumerated most of them in the
Bill of Rights that are not subject to
political negotiation you know 90% of
people don't have the ability to cancel
out your free speech right or my right
to conscience and the founders were wise
enough to put these rights to make them
inviable to put them outside the bounds
of political trampling and yet here we
are and all of this has happened just as
you say incredibly rapidly there might
have been some germs in Obama and I
think the roots of the police state go
into the aftermath of 911 but
nevertheless the the escalation in the
last couple of years is just dizzying so
that suddenly if you just go down the
Bill of Rights and list them it's hard
to think of a single right that is
completely safe the clearest example of
this in recent memory for me was when I
saw that FBI memo about the spying on
Catholic churches traditionalist extreme
radical Catholic churches or whatever
nonsense they called it and the FBI once
this memo leaked immediately disavowed
and they said oh it was an accident it
was one field office no this I don't
know how this got out there but we had
nothing to do with it and then we found
out even that testimony was a lie that
this spying was going on in multiple
field offices there were multiple
memoranda about it and you thought well
okay now I can't even trust that you're
going to do due diligence on this spying
on Americans calling parents domestic
extremists uh meanwhile when actual
domestic extremists terrorists like
antifa commit crimes they get completely
let off the hook so how did we get
here well in some ways there's some
people who would point to things like
Waco and Ruby Ridge and I think that
there are important insights to be
gained from those incidents going back
to the 1990s just to give one example I
was listening to an interview with the
the guy the FBI sniper who was brought
in to Waco after the negotiations broke
down because they were asking that guy
did you know who David Kesh was and he
goes no they go did you know what you
were up against he goes no he goes my
job is operational I'm basically a
killer and they point out and say that's
a bad guy you shoot him and and it it
gave me a little insight into the way
that police States work because they
operationalize their tasks so you have
an FB agent or an agent with the DHS the
Department of Homeland Security he's a
normal guy he's got a family he's going
lives in a three-bedroom house and he's
thinking about things in terms of I need
a promotion I want to be seen as a guy
who's on the inside who's doing the
important stuff that the FBI cares about
this is how I can retire with a pension
and so they they Define their tasks that
way and so suddenly you have a guy who's
basically a good guy and yet he's he's
storming into an apartment at 6:00 in
the morning he's grabbing a 70-year-old
grandma mother he's pulling her by the
hair he's twisting her arms behind her
back he's putting handcuffs on her
dragging her down the stairs if she
screams or resists her neighbors come
out and start gawking at her so this
monstrous behavior is being done not by
bad people but by good people who have
been incentivized in a bad way I
remember after January 6 the worst
Insurrection ever in the history of any
Republic uh I was at a cigar bar in
Washington DC and there were a couple of
US Marshals there and struck up a
conversation just having cigars and
drinks very casual and I said so how's
your job been lately and they said oh
it's awful we got to go arrest these
January Sixers who are usually perfectly
nice normal people there were some
Midwestern granny's in the group there
were some uh just otherwise nice nice
young people and he said it's awful
because we got to go and arrest them and
they're very nice and I I think it's
wrong but you know hey that's my job my
job isn't to decide who we go arrest my
job is to go actually carry it out and
and you you can just begin to see how
evil government policies can remain in
place for a very long
time absolutely the other thing about
our police state and I think this is
what makes the ordinary American
especially naive about it is that the
ordinary American has had no real
experience of police States right
America is a country defined by
innocence you can go right back to Mark
Twain and Huckleberry Finn it's like a
shock slavery really so you've got this
kind of goofball innocence and it
defines the country to a degree and so
when Americans think of police state
they're like looking for a Stalin
Overcoat a Hitler mustache they looking
for a police state in those accents but
our police state is coming stealthily
upon us and it Maser it's marching
behind the banner of Law and democracy
and fighting for truth against
misinformation and disinformation and so
it's a police state in Disguise now the
point I want to make is when a police
state is fully established it doesn't
need a disguise when Stalin's goons come
to arrest you you're on a list they
don't have to explain to you why they're
getting you they just hit you over the
head come with me but when a police
state is is in the making under
construction as I call it it needs
facade it needs deceit and so our police
state is always uh providing
rationalizations and explanations oh
yeah we're we're doing the censorship
but you know it's only because of
January 6th or you can't go to church
but that's because of coid so one
pretext after another but all in the
same direction towards subtracting one
upon another of our basic rights right
the the rationalizations don't make a
lot of sense especially when they
prattle on about democracy because they
will say that if the people elect Donald
Trump as they did in 2016 at least in
2016 they will they that would be a
threat to democracy if the hungarians
elect Victor Orban that's a threat to
democracy if the Italians elect Georgia
Maloney it's a threat to democracy you
say hold on hold on how can the majority
of people voting for something how could
that possibly be a threat of democracy
that is the definition of democracy but
when the left uses those terms they
conflate democracy with liberalism or
democracy with progressivism and so the
terms get so
confused well that and also you know
they I started out by thinking to myself
you know do I have to make the case in
this movie Are We becoming a police
state and then I realized that every
time I encounter someone who's on the
the left they agree that America's
becoming a police state but they think
that Trump and you and I are doing it
they think that we are the instruments
of the police state and so we addressed
this in the movie I restructured the
debate a little bit about who's right uh
is the police state threat coming from
the left or is it coming from the right
now if you look at Trump for example it
is amazing that this guy was not running
the police agencies of government even
in his own Administration right and
she's certainly not running them now in
fact I say in the movie I think I used
the line he's not running the police
agencies he's running away from them so
once once you realize that you begin to
ask who is in fact in control of our
police state but there's a little bit of
a wrinkle here which I think is worth
mentioning in normal police States
there's usually a dictator who is
manifestly in charge right there's
Castro uh or there's Paul pot uh or
Stalin uh right now the police state of
China is being run by XI if you consider
Russia a police state it's kind of a
quazi police state Putin okay who's
running our police state I mean our
police state has a slightly opaque
quality in that Biden is in the canoe
he's I think a willing um you know
sailor if you will but I don't think he
is moving the ores and so you have a
cabal that is evidently running this
country uh but with Biden as their kind
of a willing figurehead so then if we
can't quite figure out who it is that is
running these things and I agree but if
I found out that there were Marionette
strings attached to Joe Biden's arms
holding him up at this point I wouldn't
be surprised uh yes obviously other
people are maneuvering power uh but if
we can't figure out exactly who they are
how do we stop
them well we have to stop them uh
institutionally this is not just
something where a lot of times people
say me what can I do and there are
things you can do you know become an
election Observer become an election
judge participate to the degree you can
in the process uh but ultimately police
states are blocked by courts they're
blocked by legislatures in this case the
Republican house using its full power
they're blocked by secretaries of state
and governors and Attorneys General the
problem here I think is not that we
don't have the institutional power it is
true that we are outed and outmaneuvered
in the cultural debate the left
dominates the the big megaphones the big
institutions but the real problem I
think is that Republican psychology is
very different than the Psy ology of the
left and so if the left goes gangster on
us we say things like well we're not
going to go gangster on them because we
are too good for that we are we stand on
principle we are better than they are
now look there are circumstances where
you can say that you know you think of I
think of Jimmy Stuart in the the man who
Shard Liberty bance where if you're
living in a nice small town with a with
a sheriff and so on you can be like I'm
going to be a law order guy and if
someone tries to break into my house I'm
going to call the cops but if you go out
west in a covered wagon and you have
Outlaws with long guns encircling your
Ranch and they want to burn your
homestead and rape your wife and kill
your kids and you say I'm not going to
go get my long gun because I'm better
than they are I'm a Law and Order man
I'm a man of principle you know
something's wrong with you because you
have no grasp of the situation that you
find here so when I think about this
film it's kind of a it's kind of a
warning I liken myself to sort of an
animal that's detected a movement in the
trees and I'm trying to warn the other
wilderbeast or the antelopes that look
you know don't graze in this kind of
placid Bine way because we are all in
danger we need to take some protective
action Placid bovine way I think might
be the most apt description of a large
part of the American populace that
doesn't want to acknowledge the threats
that that really do exist this has been
a difficult issue for me speaking of Law
and Order which is that as a
conservative I've long felt that the uh
support for Law and Order and the law
enforcement agencies is a a core aspect
of of what it means to be an American
conservative and yet increasingly I see
the American law enforcement agencies
being turned against me and not just
against me but against things that are
good and true and beautiful and worth
preserving and those very same law
enforcement agencies let antifa off the
hook they let BLM off the hook they let
illegal immigration off the hook they
they they ignore the crimes and they
punish the people who are trying to
preserve the American way of life so in
those circumstances
how are conservatives supposed to think
about the police well we've got to
distinguish between a law and order that
is anchored in a legitimate system of
government and of justice and police
state so-called Law and Order police
State Law and Order is always a
desecration of true Law and Order In
fact it doesn't even do it justice to
talk about a double standard because if
we say and we're we're so good at
pointing out these double standards hey
look they're going after Trump they
never went after Biden in fact they're
covering for Biden that they went after
the January 6 guys but they don't go
after antifa they don't go after BLM
well the problem with this is that this
is itself naive because this assumes
that police states are are very rigorous
about trying to establish Equal justice
and so you've caught them out in an
inconsistency Hey listen there's a
contradiction whereas really police
states don't think like that they have a
single standard the single standard is
we protect the people who are helping to
build the police state and ruthlessly go
after the people who are a threat to the
police state and that is the consistent
way in which they operate so police
state should be expected to protect
their own and usually people who are on
the side of the police state know that
even when you know Jamal Bowman pulled
that fire alarm I'm sure that not for
one minute was he afraid that he was
going to be put into handcuffs for doing
that of course of course it reminds me
of the observation by the political
philosopher Carl Schmidt who knew a
thing or two about police States himself
who said that the the the fundamental
distinction in politics is between
friend and enemy and and if you're Jamal
Bowman and you're now you pretend like
you can't read a sign or you don't know
what a fire alarm is but of course why
was he empowered to do that because he
knew that he was a friend of the liberal
ruling Elite and there would be there
was absolutely no risk that he would
ever face any consequences even though
what he did constituted more of an
Insurrection what he did constituted
more of an obstruction of an official
Congressional proceeding than anything
the horn hat guy ever did on January
6th absolutely and the January 6 thing
when you look up close at it is very
very troubling because um I think it has
created it's not the only case of
political prisoners in the United States
but I think it is the most egregious
case and what makes it I think even more
outrageous is that this is something
ultimately where I think there was an
element of the government that wanted it
to happen I'm not saying it was entirely
orchestrated obviously there was a rally
people got out of control but they knew
it was going to get out of control and
it's almost like strategically they were
like listen guys you know what let's let
some of these guys in here because
that's when the Trap will be sprung I
mean remember they did this in the
Whitmer operation and the same guy who
ran that out of the FBI office in
Detroit transferred to DC to basically
supervise the investigations and
prosecutions of the so there's a
connection that went on there and so so
much these days of what happens with a
police at institutions is they put on a
facade right of course there's so much
artifice here I mean I think you're
seeing this in the multiple show Trials
of Donald Trump where you know they're
going to next indict him for putting too
much mustard on his ham sandwich or
something and uh and as is often the
case it's not sometimes in the case of
the Trump prosecutions sometimes they've
just kind of made it up but but in some
of the prosecutions they've caught him
doing things that might I guess sort of
technically be violations but would
never otherwise be prosecuted the great
example of this is he as president with
the power to declassify documents at
will without telling anybody uh he he
had some documents stored after his
presidency uh he's he is indicted for
this Hillary Clinton while secretary of
state with no ability to declassify
documents at will is improperly storing
them on an unsecure server where they
almost certainly were hacked by foreign
powers Donald Trump they want to put in
an orange jumpsuit Hillary Clinton gets
let off the hook by the FBI director who
who even admits what she did was wrong
and you know this very well yourself
because you were selectively prosecuted
by the Obama Administration for
something that Democrats do every
freaking day of the week and they do at
a much larger scale which is they they
give a little too much money to
Preferred political candidates you did
it at an extremely small scale but only
Desh duza ever gets prosecuted for
it you know when my case came up in
2013 I didn't see it as a Prelude to any
kind of police state I thought look uh
you know I have upset the vindictive
narcissist in the White House Obama I
made this movie and so I should have
known there's a big Target on my back
you know I've been very foolish about
this whole thing I saw it as a one-off I
didn't see it as a precursor to what
would happen to Carter page Papadopoulos
Michael Flynn of course now Trump and
yeah you're absolutely right you know if
they went after Trump on one thing Hey
listen you got this classified document
it's a nuclear secret you shouldn't have
taken it we tried to get it back you
were pugnaciously refusing to give it to
us we could look at the facts but when
you have 90 plus charges and it's like
you know it's a shotgun right if we
can't get him in DC we'll get him in
Georgia can't get him in Georgia we'll
get him in New York and can't get him in
New York on the criminal stuff so let's
destroy his business with a civil so you
can it's this is pure police state
thuggery there's no other way to look at
it um and um and so this movie is again
coming back to what we started with not
one that I would be happy of about
making I'm a little dismayed that we are
at this point where it needs to be made
we've adopted a pretty unusual strategy
we bought out hundreds of theaters and
we're showing the movie on two days
October 23rd and 25th and we're selling
tickets on our website which is
policestate fm.net the website you
mentioned uh but if and it's great to
see it in the theater because I make
these films for the theater and this is
a film that lends itself to cinematics I
mean it's it's in that way it's in a
completely different category than 2,000
muls cinematics
well and and it also I I noticed from
the very early scenes of the movie you
happen to have a particularly well-known
actor in the movie who I think it was a
few years ago was in something like
three or four of the best picture
nominated films of the year at the
Oscars you know the great International
film and television star Nick CI so
you've really got a lot of the uh High
Hollywood uh cinematography and uh film
making and this really compelling story
that we're all living every
day it brings the police state sort of
uh visually and emotionally home to
people because you and I could talk to
them about it but still the ordinary
American is going to say something like
well you know I'm not Trump and I didn't
go in the capital in January 6th and I
pay my taxes so guess what the FBI is
never going to come smashing through my
door and and this film is really aimed
at convincing that guy don't be so sure
of that we are in precarious territory
now we're not all the way there because
once the police State once the jaws of
it snap shut I can't make a movie like
this uh and in fact when a police state
is fully established the only thing you
can do is run I mean that's really the
message of refugees from North Korea or
even Soldier nen's Gulag at that point
you have to try to get out get your
family out get your money out it's only
thing you can do we don't want to get to
that point and I think fortunately we
have time and and we have room to be
able to block and roll back this police
state and that's that's the mergency of
the message of this film so the dates
are October 23rd and 25th but people
need to go get their tickets now whether
you want to see it in theaters whether
you want to see it digitally uh go right
now to policestate fm.net and get your
tickets before they sell
out thank you for coming on uh best of
luck in the rest of the media tour and I
look you know I've I've got the screener
I hate to brag to the listeners who I'm
sure want to go see the movie now I've
got the screener so I can watch it on my
phone or or computer but I'm sure it's
going to look a lot cooler in the
theater Donald Trump and the magga
Republicans represent an
extremism that threatens the very
foundations of our
Republic Chief division Council and doj
have approved a no not
breach we want the subject to be on
display l in the Walk of Shame full
visual impact
any questions are we becoming a police
state government told American citizens
they couldn't go to church on Sunday
I've never seen anything like it it may
be the Russia other people grew up in
but not my America FBI War come to the
door now there's a heavy banging at my
door open up it's 15 Mark units on my
property I got SWAT in the back of my
house it took a battering ram to my
door 6:00 a.m. I hear Boom Boom Boom and
here about 6 eight military style
Soldiers with the tallest one of them
pointing an automatic rifle at my head
FBI we have an arrest for shock you out
of sleep drag you out of your house have
clothes refuse to give you a warrant
ransack your house now I'm facing 15
years in federal prison for doing
nothing other than exercising my right
to free speech I had no reason to be
attacked I hope that you remember Matt's
name and the role you played in killing
him
how did we give the state this kind of
power 9/11 changed everything we're
going to expand the bureau from law
enforcement to domestic intelligence
legal shackles are now off it used to be
Islamic terrorism that threat is kind of
dissipated our focus is Shifting they're
moving to domestic extremists really
paints anybody who's right of Center
what we need is a person to look at and
then we go find out what crime you did
if you're a pro-life Pro Family Catholic
they Define you as radical the demand
for domestic terrorism vastly outstrips
the supply Russ interference when
candidate Trump came down the escalators
the government had a meltdown we are
going to drain the swamp we'll see about
that you take on the intelligence
Community they have six ways from Sunday
at getting back at you the Patriot Act
and fisa were used against Donald Trump
Google literally rewrote their news
algorithm based upon what Trump was
doing so they could get this guy you
just take out the word Russia gate and
you put in Co Origins you take out Co
Origins and you put in Hunter Biden's
laptop you take that out and you put in
January 6th it's the replicated play
from the deep State and their Partners
in the media they're not just
deplatforming you they are trying to
throw people in prison if they're coming
for me they're coming for you hands on
your head these are anti-government we
have freedom of religion and freedom of
speech violent extremists and they must
be dealt
with we can do anything we
want police state exclusively in
theaters October 23rd and 25th tickets
sold only on police state film.
[Music]
net